uh we're going to begin with that
breaking news we mentioned off the top
from Ukraine where deadly Russian
attacks for civilians to run for their
lives this morning in the capital city
of Kiev has multiple blasts ripped apart
busy neighborhoods photographers
captured these images on your screen now
of a so-called suicide drone it's an
unmanned aircraft which is designed to
explode on impact Holly Williams has the
latest now on these terrifying aerial
attacks
month
Center of Ukraine's Capital have been
pummeled Russia's repeatedly denied
targeting civilians but this
neighborhood is jam-packed with
apartment buildings schools and
restaurants Ukraine says the Russians
used so-called suicide drones which
explode on impact causing Devastation
the U.S says Iran has agreed to sell
several hundred of them to Moscow
today's attack comes after Russia
claimed over the weekend that Ukraine
shelled the city of Belgard just over
the border with civilians wounded
and in eastern Ukraine where the front
line extends for around 1500 miles
there's been more deadly fighting
this Ukraine's President Vladimir
zielinski claimed last night that Russia
has deployed 2 000 former prisoners to
fight there calling its state-sponsored
Terror
in the early weeks of Russia's brutal
Invasion moscow's forces moved on kieval
the Ukrainian resistance though took the
World by surprise forcing the Russians
to retreat and redirect their attacks to
the east of the country but after
Ukraine blew up a bridge in territory
occupied by Russia this month vitally
important for the Russian military
Moscow retaliated by again targeting the
Ukrainian capital
on Saturday Moscow says two of its
soldiers shot and killed 11 other
service members while they were training
at a firing range inside Russia the
Russian authorities are calling it a
terrorist attack this comes as Russia
continues its push to mobilize 300 000
reservists to beef up its forces in
Ukraine Michelle
Holly Williams thank you